comme cette illustration l’explicite.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Directement, vous traitez l’image : « Est-ce un œuf dur ? »
(Rires)
« Serait-ce l’intégrité structurelle de l’œuf
qui lui permet de supporter la charge de ce qui semble être un rocher ?
Mais, est-ce vraiment un rocher ? »
Nous prenons du recul devant une information visuelle.
Mais quand l'information est auditive, voici ce qui arrive.
(Rires)
Les vannes de notre esprit s’ouvrent comme les rues de Shanghai.
(Applaudissements)
Il y a tant d’informations à traiter,
tant d’idées, de concepts, de sentiments et, bien sûr, de vulnérabilités
que nous préférons souvent ne pas partager.
Alors, on se cache.
On se cache derrière ce que nous avons nommé la vanne de l’intimité.
(Rires)
Que peut bien contenir cette vanne de l’intimité ?
Sur quel barrage est-elle posée ?
Eh bien, tout d'abord --
(Rires)
nous avons découvert que ça varie selon six génotypes.
(Applaudissements)
Nous pouvions dès lors commencer à catégoriser ces génotypes
en expériences neuronormative et neurodiverse.
(Rires)
À droite de l’écran,
les pics que l’on observe sont relatives à la pensée neurodiverse.
En général, seuls deux états émotionnels peuvent être calibrés simultanément
par le cerveau neurodivers, quel que soit le moment.
Par conséquent, cela élimine, parfois, la possibilité d’être émotionnellement
en phase avec la situation présente.
Mais à gauche de l’écran, on observe le cerveau neuronormatif.
Celui-ci est souvent capable de traiter cinq éléments
d’informations cognitives émotionnelles, à n’importe quel moment.
Ici, on a les écarts infimes
dans les 75, 90 et 60 percentiles.
Et ici, les variations spectaculaires
dans les 25, 40 et 35 percentiles.
(Rires)
Mais alors, quel est le réseau neural
qui permet de relier et construire ces disparités ?
(Rires)
La peur.
(Applaudissements)
Comme nous le savons tous, la peur se situe dans l’amygdale.
C'est une réaction très naturelle
qui est fortement liée à la perception visuelle.
Toutefois, elle est peu liée à la perception verbale.
C'est pourquoi nos récepteurs de la peur vont se déclencher
avant que nous ayons perçu un quelconque indice cognitif verbal
ou de langue.
Dès lors, quand nous voyons un moment de peur,
nous sommes naturellement décontenancés.
Nous trébuchons dans une direction précise,
qui, généralement, s'éloigne de l'intimité.
(Rires)
À cela s'ajoute évidemment la différence de perception
entre les hommes et les femmes,
les trans et toutes les nuances de personnes au sein
et en dehors du spectre des genres.
(Rires)
Mais la peur est la base sous-jacente
de la totalité de nos systèmes de réaction.
La réaction la plus immédiate est de faire face ou de s'enfuir.
Certains parlent d'une réaction reptilienne à notre environnement.
Comment pouvons-nous nous extirper
ou nous décrocher des cornes de notre amygdale ?
(Rires)
Je vais vous dévoiler le secret.
(Applaudissements)
Tout ceci est bien trop sensé !
(Rires)
La clé
consiste à nous tourner le dos les uns aux autres.
Je suis conscient que cela semble à l'opposé
de ce que vous vous attendiez.
Mais dans une relation, quand on tourne le dos à son partenaire
et qu'on repose son dos contre celui de l'autre --
(Rires)
on élimine dans la foulée les indications visuelles.
(Applaudissements)
On est davantage vulnérable
à faillir le premier
et faillir en premier --
(Rires)
dépasse largement tous nos efforts
de séduction vis-à-vis des autres,
qu'il s'agisse de nos partenaires ou de nous-même.
Nous dépensons des millions et des millions
dans la mode, en produits cosmétiques,
pour les lunettes à la mode.
Toutefois, nous ne dépensons ni temps, ni argent
dans notre connexion avec les autres
de manière sincère,
honnête
et dénudée de tous récepteurs visuels.
(Applaudissements)
(Rires)
La réalité est dure, n'est-ce pas ?
Mais nous souhaitons être assertifs à ce sujet.
On ne veut pas rester couché sur le divan.
Comme un historien l'a dit,
c'est crucial de se relever et de parfois échapper au divan.
Comment pouvons-nous y arriver ?
L'important est ici.
Idées, Compassion et Identification.
I - C - I.
(Applaudissements)
Dès qu'on a commencé à utiliser cette méthode,
le potentiel nous a dépassés.
En fait, plus petit que vous.
Au niveau moléculaire,
je pense que cette intuition
est le thème unificateur
pour toutes les interventions TED que vous avez écoutées,
qui va nous accompagner sur notre trajectoire,
pendant notre séjour sur cette petite planète,
au bord de la falaise, du précipice,
quand on voit arriver l'inévitable fin.
(Rires)
La mort nous atteindra-t-elle tous simultanément ?
C'est la variable que nous tentons de résoudre actuellement.
(Rires)
Je suis convaincu que la ligne du temps s'étire un peu
quand on utilise ici
et quand on se repose dos à dos,
que l'on construit ensemble,
abandonnant derrière nous la peur,
progressant vers l'avant --
(Rires)
ça va être coupé au montage --
une expérience affinée de l'amour,
la compassion,
l'intimité ancrée dans la vérité
que nous partageons avec les yeux de notre cœur
et le cœur qu'on peut toucher,
sentir avec nos doigts,
ont tous deux le potentiel de devenir un moment fondant
qu'on ne peut se résoudre à rejeter parce qu'il a un peu bruni.
Mais découpons notre expérience accumulée,
laissons éclore le cœur, le noyau,
la graine de l'idée qui existe en chacun de nous
et partageons-la, dos à dos.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)